welcome back to the Rich Eisen show is
football morning in America Monday
column on Pro Football Talk is a an NBC
sports is a must read as it has been for
decades he's our friend Peter King back
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
Peter everything is going okay rich how
about you I'm doing fine everybody happy
and healthy in your world relatively
speaking
I mean it's I'm in Brooklyn I'm sort of
in the belly of the beast right we're
all alive and we're all staying safe and
and basically being as careful as we can
be and we're all very healthy but thank
you knocking on wood for that okay Peter
you and I spoke last week he gave me a
call at the end of last week or we
connected for your Monday column about
the draft and what it may look like
based on where things are right now what
do you think the NFL draft looks like
for later on next month we can't wait to
turn the page to April what do you got
for me on that well one of the rich one
of the things that and again I don't I
don't know who pays attention what but
one of the things I thought that was
lost in whatever discussion there was of
the the scene I set for the draft in my
column which I believe will be either at
a at a very barren ESPN studio in
Bristol Connecticut because obviously
Gavin Newsom is not letting NFL Network
open up and Phil Murphy the Governor of
New Jersey is not going to let NFL Films
open up New York is certainly not going
to be open at that time and there's a
chance that ESPN could be open and this
could be time when you know and who
knows maybe you will be a part of this
for NFL Network maybe this will just be
ESPN but ESPN might have three or four
people on a baron set at ESPN and then a
bunch of people essentially on a you
know on their in-home cameras or as you
and I discussed it could it could also
be Rich Eisen in
home in California hosting it and
kicking it out to Kurt Warner in Arizona
and and everybody everywhere else
you know he and Rappaport wherever he is
in New York you know so but I do think I
do think that and you raised this point
because I asked about it I said look
there's a real chance that Roger Goodell
could host this draft from his home in
Bronxville New York and there is a real
chance that that could happen but I
think as far as teams go I think I think
what we're seeing with teams is they
really are waiting to hear from the NFL
if their facilities will be open so that
maybe four or five people per team could
be available to use their facilities now
a lot of people might say well geez why
can't you know everybody just get
together for each team buy zoom or buy
conference call or something well they
can and they might you know but I was in
the San Francisco 49ers draft room in
2017 for their entire draft process of
the new staff John Elway Kyle Shanahan
Adam Peters Parag Marathe obviously was
a holdover there their business and cab
guy and they must have spent over a
million dollars totally revamping the
technology in their drafter it's amazing
how much knowledge you could get up on
any player in the draft okay and
obviously if you do that everybody's
sitting in their homes or whatever it's
going to be difficult to do that you're
not going to be able to take advantage
of it so everybody in the NFL wants to
be even a very skeleton crew at their
facility but they have to prepare in
another way because Roger Goodell has
made it clear if all 32 teams are not
allowed to be in their facility on April
23 24 and 25 that none of the 32 will be
able to be allowed in their facility and
they'll all have to make alternative
plans so is this like a
we'll track process for tennis right now
is like did pending them and when and by
when do you know that is the call made
you know what rich I just
I literally just talked to John Elway
fifteen minutes ago
yeah about this and he said in essence
that we're hopeful of getting in our
facility and we're making plans
otherwise if we can't so I think all 32
teams are in the exact same boat I'm
sure I'm sure that Roger Goodell will
make that ruling he's gonna have to do
it I would say at the very least like a
week before the draft because teams are
going to have to figure out a way to get
the plans for the draft and and let's
just say you're you might draft you
might dress see deal and okay everyone
is going to have to have either an IT
person make it possible for them to call
up every bit of information they have in
their organization on CD Lam every
scouting report everything so that when
they're in the process of discussing hey
what are we doing here or in their final
draft meetings the few days before the
draft they're all going to have to find
some way to get if not on exactly the
same page close to the same page I mean
the Internet technology community in the
NFL right now is is that a premium
clearly almost as important as as the
actual scouting information and just
trying to house it in a way to make it
as close to what what these teams are
used to Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show and you had Mickey Loomis on
your podcast him saying how he'd be
personally in favor of delaying the
draft which went all sorts of viral
certainly it landed as appears as with a
thud on the desk of Commissioner Roger
Goodell I'm wondering where where all
that sentiment sentiment resides right
now in the NFL community well I think
there's a lot of people a lot of front
office people GM types we're not happy
with Roger Goodell because this was not
a time in my opinion to be relatively
autocratic which Roger Goodell was this
was a
to come out and say hey look we
understand this is a tough time for all
general managers in this league for all
Scouts in this league because rich right
now this week you know quite literally
starting on March 30th is when several
teams in this league and I think it's
probably more than several we're going
to start like two weeks of Draft
meetings in which they would finalize
their board they get their board
finished and now they haven't been able
to do anything out of a sense of
normalcy for the last month and now
clearly nothing is going to be normal
over the next three weeks before the
draft and I think sometimes I mean Roger
Goodell has gotten more and more removed
from a lot of sort of the common people
in the league recently I mean he was big
this is the NFL hundred season he was
absolutely invisible all year I mean
nobody saw him I mean if he made five
public appearances I don't I can't even
name him but normally Roger Goodell is a
guy who in his tenure has when he goes
to a game he walks through the parking
lot sometimes or or speaks to some fan
groups or whatever and it's possible he
did this this year in abundance I I
certainly didn't hear about very much of
it and and look whatever you think of
the job you did or whatever in my
opinion had I been advising Roger
Goodell I would have said hey pick up
the phone call Mickey Loomis call ten
general managers and say hey I know this
is tough or have a conference call with
them and say hey I'm sorry I feel for
you guys this is a hard way to go but we
got to do this draft now could he have
done could he have reached out to a
couple three four or five I I don't know
I have not heard of that and maybe he
could have but in my opinion one of the
reasons that a lot of general managers
and football people in the league feel
enmity right now toward the the league
office is they feel like they're not
listened to well you know we're kind of
recreating the conversate
you and I had on the phone last week
where you know I'm I heard that and I
I'm like wow you know I didn't really
consider all that cuz all I'm just
talking about where I am from my chair
talking to fans and hearing from fans
and where I would be in my chair for a
draft and oh you mentioned how it would
be maybe an ESPN only event that would
be over a lot of people the NFL
network's if you will there would be an
issue
III think I don't use that word
obviously in this day and age but you
know what I'm saying like it would be
very difficult for all of us to handle
all that but these are unique times man
like and that's when I say you know with
with with all with all the scouts and
the general managers and I know that
they're not doing it the way that they
normally would do it and I understand
their livelihoods are on the line if
they don't get it right usually but if
things are in this country necessary for
the fans to get some form of a
distraction
what three-day event could there
possibly be at all in the sports world
that comes remotely close to this I mean
we're talking about a Jordan documentary
being something to celebrate being moved
up by two months so you know we talk
about adversity in the third and the
fourth quarters and how you have to
adapt and you have maybe maybe it's time
for the scouting and general manager
departments to adapt and I believe that
you know I've talked to I talk to like
four or five of them this weekend and
nobody is bitching and moaning right now
it's it's simply and I don't mean oh you
know you poor guys and give him a pat on
the back I just mean you know talk to
him he he'll talk to him show a little
bit of empathy in just this this league
office has not been able to do that and
again maybe they've done it behind
closed doors it's possible but it's
certainly not anything that I've I've
heard about Peter King here on the Rich
Eisen show all right let's get to other
aspects of the business that the
Commissioner is sitting right in the
middle of
and that is the the owners meeting that
would have happened and the rules of the
NFL is is pass interference where's that
situation right now what's really
interesting I heard this weekend that
they have not gotten into the nuts and
bolts of what they want to do with pass
interference because the competition
committee knew that there was not going
to be a vote on this this week okay and
so their whole feeling is we have a
bunch of things we need to do now that
quite frankly are more important than
the clarification of this rule so the
competition committee is going to take
all of this up in the coming weeks and
then there's going to be a resolution on
it before the May meetings now most
likely the May meetings will also be
virtual because the competition
committee meetings are going to be
virtual they held some last week but
they basically realize that we don't we
don't really have time to get everybody
involved in this right now obviously
there's a lot of these things that the
coaches want to be involved in heavily
and want to be heard and so I think they
all felt like this is something that's
going to be better done you know in the
weeks before the May meetings especially
because now there was going to be no way
that they were gonna come to any sort of
resolution with everything else they
have going on so then what are the votes
that they do have in front of them are
they television related scheduled
related and how exactly just confirming
what exactly will be done with the extra
two playoff teams right okay so as
everybody knows playoff thing goes up
from 12 teams to 14 one additional one
per per conference almost certainly the
the seeding will remain exactly the same
you will not recede after every thing
EAF
after every round basically it is going
to be very simply playoffs as usual with
the expiring with the exception of now
there's only going to be one team with a
bye and so obviously it's 2 versus 7 3
vs 6 4 vs. 5 4 vs. 5 there's two other
little things which TV networks get the
games right that's one thing and then
say then the final thing is just
confirming that this is going to be
three wild card games on Saturday three
on Sunday which is how my understanding
is that's what will be announced later
today but there is a chance rich in the
future in future years of this CBA that
they will experiment with a Monday night
game in wildcard weekend because if you
think about it the amount of the amount
of people who would watch Monday at 8:15
versus Saturday at 1:05 right is I think
it could be double the audience I agree
it's not even close but then there's the
issue of whoever wins that game would
have to play a game on Sunday the
following week you can't go Monday to
Saturday I mean that would be know what
your competitive disadvantage here's the
thing here's what I would say about that
if you're going on a short week after
playing the previous Sunday right to
play on Saturday okay and also to play
the early game on Saturday you're
playing at 1:05 p.m. because that's the
game that would be eliminated in a two
three one situation to Saturday 3:00
Sunday 1:00 Monday so how big of a
difference honestly is it to have a
short week afternoon game you know in
week one of the in the in the division
round versus right winning that game and
having a short week game the following
Sunday and he changed I really don't
think it's that big a deal
any chance that ownership just comes out
and says whichever
happens the one o'clock on Saturday or
4:30 on Saturday the Texans get that
game regardless because that's the way
it goes
possible they actually make a rule
that's a new league the Texans make it
card weekend at 3:35 Central has to be
must a League rule it is that's what
they're voting I should just make it
they should just codify Peter and be
done with it he'll never play a
prime-time playoff game in his life all
right last one for you Peter before I
let you go the markets for Cam Newton
and Jameis Winston do you think they get
signed before the draft I think they got
to see how that goes and then and then
we'll see how it goes after that right
right now my gut feeling is the only
team that might sign one of them before
the draft is Jacksonville and and quite
honestly rich Jacksonville any because
hey look you think and I think we all
think that because Tom telesco and the
Chargers are really a heavy draft and
develop team I keep thinking man the
Chargers you know with the sixth pick in
the draft I really view them as a
long-term quarterback pick right there
Justin Herbert Jordan love whoever but
and so and so I don't think it would be
the Chargers before the draft but I just
can't imagine the Jacksonville Jaguars
not taking one of those players at a low
cost for for like a year or two I mean
what why wouldn't you why wouldn't you
do that and and I don't know which one I
don't I don't have any idea which one
they'd be interested in but they sure
they sure seem like the most logical
landing spot for one of those two and
then you know I know you you mentioned
Pittsburgh is a great spot for Jameis
few weeks ago you said the bird would be
fantastic but they I'm told I was told
last week they have zero interest in
Jameis Winston so I mean just because I
think it's a good idea
necessarily mean they do the reason it
it'd be great for him is that I think it
would be great for him to be a backup
for a year get some tough love from Mike
Tomlin bond with those guys and
basically step in on opening day 20 21
or maybe even earlier Ben Roethlisberger
has not exactly been the Iron Horse and
and you know all I can say is he
obviously needs to cut down the
turnovers we know that but he shown
quite a lot of promise in every other
area on and off the field in the last
couple of years I think he'd be an
excellent risk to take if I was if I
were if I needed an heir to my
quarterback throne I just can't believe
and I understand part of cams issue
unfortunately for for him professionally
and I say that fully knowing what it
means for our general world population
personally and health-wise what's going
on with the coronavirus preventing him
from being seen by doctors potentially
is creating his situation I just can't
believe a first overall picked former
MVP we're just five years removed now
from his MVP sees and kids 30 he is
still a kid and a guy who led the league
in passing in it so totally it's so
totally unprecedented okay in the last
year and a half of football Cam Newton
has first of all in the first half is in
the in the last half of 2018 didn't win
a game because of his shoulder he was
lousy you know he just was and he tried
to play through it and he just couldn't
do it then he has a shoulder surgery
then he hurts his foot knee as the foot
surgery so I understand and I've heard
this a thousand times in the last two
weeks oh my god Cam Newton just sitting
out there why aren't teams pouncing on
this is a different time than anybody
has ever gone through in terms of player
procurement why how could you devote any
significant amount of money right
now on your salary cap to a guy who you
think is okay and all that plus is a
different kind of quarterback for a lot
of teams systems he told me last summer
that he was he was ready to go into the
second phase in his life he was going to
be a different quarterback he was going
to learn how to play differently well
then that got interrupted so who is he
how is he
what is he that's the reason why there's
not a gold rush for Cam Newton Peter
thanks for the time at Peter underscore
King check out everything that Peter
does on NBC sports.com Pro Football Talk
as well Peter your podcast is also great
for folks to listen to and pass the time
certainly is where we're all waiting
this thing out thanks for the call
really appreciate it
you're welcome right back at you that's
Peter King nobody liked him